most important if they be the wrist
straps so they when you put the rest
wrap on actually there's a little shape
here the plus and a plus so you kind of
just you make so scoot up now all right
you're on debt so no buttons involved
for this one the zr button is gonna act
as your trigger with your right index
finger
zr your right index finger so it's like
just got to attach you got your back
scratcher and then you're going to don't
pull the trigger until you're kind of
aiming sort of at like your opponent
right if you pull the trigger too early
you'll shoot the dirt okay so you don't
want for my toe and the audio cube will
say ready steady fire and on fire that's
when you the grill mind you really not
to stare each other down for this one
this isn't straight down okay
[Music]
fire
that wasn't me shooting myself in the
foot well you realize another don't you
see this twice this is a stand up case
we're gonna use the wrists great so
let's watch the intro video briefly here
[Music]
so so you're going to face each other
with the joy con and you're going to run
in place as you're running towards a
flag on the beach once you feel the
vibration in your hand you're gonna pull
the flag up out of the sand family game
a beach flag so so you're gonna be yeah
kinda like this right but much faster
alright alright and to start you're
gonna sink your joy calm by holding up
in a second and a pull flag is the just
lift up the art just yeah just like
Valerie's doing hold up hold up just
like that yep wait for it wait for it
you look at each other too